tell me you have high functioning anxiety
and perfectionist procrastination without telling me
I'll go first
cause painting my wardrobe wasn't on my bingo card for today
or any day for that matter
but I guess that's what happens when you
allow an adult with undiagnosed ADHD
Make her own life decisions
but in my defence
it did feel very important at the time
so there’s that
as you can see my room was - for lack of a better word - fkd
And please excuse the fact that there's no sheets on the bed
I'm currently washing them and in hindsight
that's probably what set me off
actually I think there's a few things that set me off
firstly I'm going away next month and I have no idea what to pack
and secondly
the seasons are changing rapidly here in Aotearoa
New Zealand and it suddenly gone from
mild to colder than a witch's tit
so I needed to do a stock take of sorts
An inventory if you like
which is another way of saying
I needed to figure out what the hell I'm
actually keeping in this cupboard
and it turns out the cupboard itself was actually another contributing factor
and I'm gonna go ahead and assume that you remember my last house
and the beautiful walk-in robe that I used to have
now I have a cupboard that reminds me of when I was a student
and it also smells like when I was a student
which means all of my winter clothes smell
like absolute ass unfortunately
but we're gonna deal with the clothes in a second
cause right now I'm just wiping out the cupboard with bleach
and that was about the time that I noticed that not only was it mouldy
but also all of the wallpaper had these tiny holes in it
Side note
but one day I'm gonna rip this whole cupboard out
and bust through this wall into the next room
and turn it into a walk in robe slash ensuite
but that day is not today
today we're just gonna make it
I don't know not disgusting?
and then my husband walked in and saw the
enormous mess that I've made
and the fact that I was painting a cupboard
and he was surprised
but not surprised surprised
do you know what I mean
and fun fact
well fun if you're anything like me
but this paint actually has a mould killer in it
so I'm telling myself it's gonna help me in the long run
so while I was organising my clothes
I made a few piles. I made a pile of summer stuff
which I don't need to see until pie season is over
and I've put them into another cupboard
I made a pile of winter clothes which needed a bit of TLC
and so I got started on approximately 75 loads of washing and yep
I'm trimming a coat
and I made a pile of things to sell slash donate
once I successfully turned my entire house into a laundromat
it was time to get started on visually merchandizing my shit
and I'm a big fan of visually merchandizing your shit
cause even though my cupboard is tiny
doesn't mean she can't still be cute
and I wanna open this door and feel like I'm stepping into a shop
do you know what I mean this shop looks like
it's just been the victim of a ram raid
but we'll get there
and by the end of the afternoon
after a lot of interruptions
everything was finally where it needed to be
and I was putting fresh sheets on the bed
called it a day, had a wee sleep
and then this is how we pulled up this morning
Can’t believe I'm showing you again
but yep this is how we started
and this is how we're looking now
full disclosure
I do still need to pop a couple of coats and
jackets in here when they dry
but there's plenty of room
and now I actually know what I own, which is good
I also sorted out my t shirts
my singlets old jerseys and pants
and I even have a whole spare drawer
which is exciting and in this cupboard
I've got tracksuits Pjs
loungewear and some spare activewear
but I'm super into my yoga at the moment
and the hardest thing for me is actually finding my gear
so I've dedicated a whole rack to all my favourite activewear
so I can just get up in the morning
choose an outfit and get to class